[Música]
y en directo Vamos hasta Roma donde
conectamos con nuestra corresponsal
Natalia Mendoza vamos a hablar sobre el
voto de confianza que ganó en el
parlamento la nueva primera ministra de
ese país Georgia meloni también sobre su
plan de gobierno de Cara a estos cinco
años y además dejó ver sus principales
propuestas Natalia muy buenas noches
cuéntenos Cuáles son las primeras
medidas que adoptará meloni
el parlamento italiano votó la confianza
del gobierno de Georgia melón y con 235
votos a favor de un total de 400
parlamentarios en la cámara de diputados
Este martes un voto que concluyó una
jornada iniciada con el discurso de la
líder de la ultraderecha italiana en el
cual presentó su programa de gobierno en
particular las medidas previstas para
hacer frente a los desafíos económicos
que deberá afrontar este gobierno frente
al impacto económico de la guerra en
Ucrania y el aumento de la inflación que
golpea a Italia la tercera economía de
la zona Euro melón y prometió ayudas
financieras a familias y empresas
golpeadas por el aumento del precio del
gas de la electricidad y la gasolina
también anunció reducciones de impuestos
y hasta una amnistía fiscal para
reactivar el crecimiento de la economía
italiana prometió una serie de reformas
del sistema fiscal de la Administración
pública y de la justicia italiana
Natalia que ha dicho Georgia melón y de
su relación con Europa
a nivel internacional melón y confirmó
su
voluntad sigue haciendo parte de la
Unión Europea y contribuya a su
consolidación aseguró que el objetivo de
Italia no será frenar o sabotear la
Unión Europea dijo melón y sino hacerla
más eficaz siempre y cuando se respete
la soberanía y el interés Nacional de
Italia reiteró que Italia seguirá siendo
un socio leal de la otan y confirmó el
apoyo al pueblo ucraniano que se opone a
la invasión de la federación rusa no hay
que ceder ante el chantaje de Vladimir
Putin dijo meloni evocando el suministro
de gas ruso a la Unión Europea